da habe ich wirklich die hände über dem
kopf zusammengeschlagen
das gebe ich gerne zu bei gut ich bin
vater von drei töchtern
da ist vielleicht nicht ganz so
neutralen objektiv aber ich muss ganz
offen sagen natürlich ist
kindsmissbrauch kindesmissbrauch aus
meiner sicht immer ein verbrechen
ich verstehe das argument dass gerichte
die möglichkeit haben müssen zwischen
schweren und weniger schweren straftaten
zu unterscheiden aber diesen spielraum
haben gerichte natürlich auch wenn die
mindeststrafe ein jahr freiheitsstrafe
ist und dann das ganze eben wirklich als
verbrechen gewertet wird noch schlimmer
finde ich allerdings diejenigen die sich
versuchen in den besitz von
kinderpornografie zu bekommen zu
bekommen und die solche videos drehen
denn eins ist klar da wo es die
nachfrage gibt da gibt es am ende auch
ein angebot ich finde die müssen genau
so abgestraft werden wenn die strafe
nicht noch härter ich finde das ist
wirklich ein schlimmes verbrechen mit
dem der not und der seelennot von
kindern geschäfte zu machen da bin ich
auch dafür dass wir nicht nur diejenigen
die als täter kinder missbrauchen
bestrafen sondern auch die sich in den
besitz von kinderpornografie bringen
denn die sind auslöser die machen das
geschäft aus dass es hier gibt und ich
finde da muss der staat mit aller härte
zu lange